on est bien peu de chose et mon amie la
rose me l'a dit ce matin
alors je suis né baptisé ne rentrent et
je me suis épanoui
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre émission
le petit émir lors de l'épisode
précédent nous avons quitté marica après
un spectacle donné au centre de la
ressource par les jeunes comédiens que
nous avions découvert dans les épisodes
1 et 3 notre metteur en scène avait
alors pu se faire une idée plus précise
des capacités des élèves en situation de
spectacles réel elle souhaite maintenant
rencontrer individuellement les jeunes
pour leur annoncer ses choix et en
savoir plus sur leurs motivations
le prochain spectacle que l'on va faire
j'aimerais y participent est ce que toi
ça te dit de faire oui oui
est ce que tu aimes vers la bible
oui
est ce que tu sais danser
bon
oui ouais
tu peux me montrer
c'est à présent au tour de thomas qui
vous allez le voir va impressionner
marica par ses pas de danse
j'étais comprendre entraînés à faire le
mieux oui bien sûr
je me suis entraîné j'étais très
concentré j'étais très sérieux aussi est
ce que tu sais danser
m
moi je suis pas
méchante entendent mimi la voiture balai
ville de faire un accident
on va travailler par contrainte parce
qu'il faudrait être rigoureuse et que tu
m'écoutes vient dans mes consignes
voilà ce que c'est du théâtre qui aura
plein de monde à
g partant travailler avec moi
place maintenant à adeline qui a bluffé
marica par sa prestation sur scène avec
sa marionnette j'ai l'habitude que les
après-midi de faire du mime
plus tard j'ai envie de faire ça j'ai
l'habitude du mil
carnaval carnaval
faire plein de choses comme ça j'aime
bien participer à ça est-ce que tu
partante pour faire du spectacle avec
nous alors le petit enis
d'accord oui patrice après on se voit se
rencontrer en montrer toute l'équipe et
on va gré comme une trousse de
moi j'ai envie de faire ce mines des
fois j'ai un petit peu de honte mais
j'ai pris mon courage à deux mains et
devant toute la foule
c'est enfin au tour de zidane qui a
particulièrement marqué la metteuse en
scène bon alors c'était bien le
tuer mais
alors qu'est ce que ça te fais toi quand
tu joues les personnages de nîmes comme
ça
j'en avais tu as m avec tes amis
sur scène ça fait quoi
ça fait quoi tu te sens bien pas bien tu
t'en j'aime bien
à l'aise quand diffusé comme ça là quoi
tu fais ça pour quoi tu ta pas dans les
mains mais
on montre aux gens tels que j'ai fait
voilà donc sur déjà c'était beau ce
geste c'était toi qu'il faisait très
lentement donc moi quand je t'ai vu sur
scène je pense que tu as vraiment du
potentiel
est ce qu'on aimerait voir c'est des
autres capacités en termes de textes de
chant de danse aussi est ce que tu veux
me montrer un peu des choses là tout de
suite
j'ai chanté
oui c'est chanter est ce que tu peux me
sentais un petit truc
ben ali mon père m'a donné des
consignes à monza michel comment la
mettre la main comme la mecque elle est
allée pour nous yes
bon on va s'en servir de tout ça on va
s'en servir sur spectacle donc le seul
truc qu'on a c'est le rôle principal
qu'on te propose à le petit émirat qu'il
faudra avoir une mémoire d'éléphant ce
que le texte il est comme ça il est
assez long à prendre donc en plus rares
mais il faudra vraiment du travail sur
la mémoire
qui a envie d'avoir ce spectacle avec
nous mais j'en remets
donc c'est un challenge là pendant six
mois va poser un four à la maison
d'avoir tu passes
cette émission s'achève donc avec de
bonnes nouvelles pour ces quatre
comédiens qui font désormais partie de
la troupe du petit émir dans les
prochains épisodes
marica ira à la rencontre des élèves du
centre de sainte suzanne et de la
montagne que nous avions découvert lors
des épisodes 2 et 4 elle leur annoncera
ses choix et mènera de nouveau des
entretiens individuels afin de
poursuivre la construction de la future
troupe du petit émir à très bientôt donc